fleurs new book the bureau chronicles
the history of the FBI from its
beginnings in 1908 through the bureau's
response to the attacks of September
11th and it's aftermath he focuses
specifically on J edgar Hoover's tenure
as director and offers a critical
assessment of Lois freeze management of
the FBI this program runs an hour and 25
minutes
are we on we are well good evening and
welcome to Barnes & Noble and welcome
again to c-span book TV is here tonight
with us for those of you who like to
bring author events into your living
room you need to check out book TV it's
on every weekend on c-span 2 for 48
hours and I believe this program is
actually going to be playing I was going
to be on TV this weekend we don't know
the time but if you check book TV org if
you want a repetition of tonight's event
we shall have another opportunity to do
so before we invite mr. Kessler to the
microphone of course I'd like to say a
few introductory words about him of
course I don't think we've had an event
a book discussion in this store as
timely my dad perhaps unfortunately as
tonight but we are grateful that there
are scholars like mr. Kessler who do
this research for us so when we really
need to focus in on things that are
important to our society we have the
resources at our hand so I welcome to
mr. Ronald Kessler for being with us
here tonight mr. Kessler is a New York
Times bestselling author of 13
non-fiction books we actually have a few
of the titles here he began his career
as an investigative journalist in 1964
and the worst the worst a telegram
and followed with three years as an
investigative reporter an editorial
writer with the Boston Herald mr. Kessel
then joined the New York Bureau of The
Wall Street Journal in 1968 in 1970 he
became an investigative reporter with
the Washington Post and he continued as
a staff writer till 1985 mr. Kessler has
won 16 awards in journalism including
two George Polk Awards one for national
reporting and one for community service
he won the top prize for business and
financial reporting given by the
Washington chapter of the Sigma Delta
Chi Society of Professional Journalists
he also won the American political
science associations public affairs
reporting award and The Associated
Press's s Brown Memorial Award as well
as the Washingtonians magazine's
Washingtonians of the Year award he is
listed in Who's Who in America and he is
a near neighbor of ours of losing
Potomac so please join me in welcoming
mr. Ronald Kessler it's good
thank you very much Esther it's a
pleasure to be here at my neighborhood
Barnes and Noble and I appreciate your
all coming the favorite story of FBI
agents is called the roast beef sandwich
story it seems that an agent in the New
York field office which is where all the
strange stories originated went around
the corner from the field office to the
local deli and he thought it was one of
those deli delis that offers a special
deal or one of these eating
establishments that offers a special
deal or discount to FBI agents or law
enforcement so he ordered a roast beef
sandwich and the cattlemen put on the
slices and pushed it towards him and the
agent looked at it and it just wasn't
anything special it wasn't any extra
meat there so he pulled out his FBI
credentials and said FBI more roast beef
and the guy just looked at him because
it was not one of those special
establishments and the story just spread
all the way through the FBI and so it
always creates tremendous peals of
laughter when when agents tell it when
agents say they showed their credentials
to a suspect or to someone who's been
arrested they say I roast-beef them or
when they complain about anything they
say more roast beef and the story sort
of is very relevant to the FBI because
the FBI does have this tremendous power
power to make arrest power to kill
someone under certain circumstances if
an agent is threatened or if someone
else is threatened power new wiretap
videotape what goes on in a bedroom to
look up information in files get
information from the CIA from foreign
intelligence services any number of
things including going into movie
theaters free and and parking illegally
and not getting tickets but of course it
all has to be done under the authority
of law and it made in many cases with a
court order and
of course brings us to some of the
current controversies about the FBI and
civil liberties and also leads us to why
I am so fascinated by the FBI and have
done two books on the FBI as well as
several related to the FBI and that is
that it is not only an agency full of
secrets not only an agency that's so
important to our American freedoms but
also is such a powerful agency one that
can very easily go off course and it
certainly has in the past and so I'm I'm
fascinated by power and by secrets I
like the challenge of penetrating those
secrets and I think it's is a worthwhile
subject given its importance jeager
Hoover of course basically started the
FBI when this when the FBI started
before Hoover in 1908 no one had even
heard of the agency it was only 34
agents they were established because
they had a few federal laws in the books
that needed enforcing they had
previously been enforced by Secret
Service agents such as
antitrust laws which were criminal in
nature and two years after the
establishment of the FBI having trouble
with this it's loud
okay thank you
great two years after the establishment
of the FBI there was the Mann Act which
prohibited transporting women across
state lines for immoral purposes today
we have 300 federal laws that the FBI
enforces when Hoover took over in 1924
he immediately established this agency
as a very accountable agency with
special agent in charge of field offices
each reporting directly to Hoover each
responsible for the agents under their
jurisdiction Hoover also established a
very consistent way for reporting
information for writing up interview
reports for filing the information and
initially was very innovative
technologically he established the FBI
laboratory when when that was very
unusual to have a forensic laboratory
and really created this organization as
a very forward-looking agency over time
however Hoover began to engage in a
number of abuses ranging from illegal
wiretapping tape recording Martin Luther
King's sexual activities for the purpose
of leaking material to the press using
FBI funds to maintain his home and
perhaps most significant significantly
keeping files for blackmail purposes on
members of Congress presidents and
celebrities this was really the
guarantee of Hoover's job security and
in fact he was director for 48 years
largely because of this Nixon and
Johnson both said that they were afraid
to fire Hoover because he had so much
material on them and of course Hoover
made it clear to the people he had this
material about that he knew what they
were doing he would say to JFK you know
we know we understand you've been having
this affair with Judith Exner of course
we'll say nothing of it that was always
the perception the rumor
that was enough to keep people in line
so that whoever got what he wanted but
until this book the actual specifics had
not been documented in one specific was
that Senator Carl Hayden who was over
the Appropriations Committee was opposed
to an increase in the budget for the FBI
jeager Hoover Building and so Hoover
sent over his a kartha deloach his
congressional liaison to me with
Hayden's top aide Rory Ellison and
DeLoach said we really need this money
and we understand from her files that
you've been having some extramarital
affairs and Roy Olson said well I hope
you have photographs because I want to
show the boss and that was the end of
that blackmail attempt but that is
exactly the way Hoover operated and it
was enough to keep a large number of
people in this country in fear basically
the FBI was the moral arbiter of the
country the FBI also engaged in
gathering information on political
dissidents largely at the direction of
presidents but Hoover would encourage
this and so you had a very very bad
situation and abuse of rights when
Hoover died and some still think he's in
the FBI basement waiting to come back
Clarence Kelley became director and he
started the FBI moving towards the
modern agency
first of all stopping the abuses
secondly because of the church committee
revelations about the abuses making sure
that the FBI did not engage in illegal
wiretapping or keeping files and members
of Congress but also moving the agency
towards becoming much more effective
because Hoover ignored a lot of areas of
crimes such as organized crime and even
political corruption again in my opinion
because he wanted to keep his job he
didn't want to take on powerful mafia
figures or even congressmen who might
topple him because all you know really
cared about
ultimately was his job there was this
theory that the reason he didn't go
after organized crime was that he was a
crossdresser and that the Mafia had
blackmail material on him I went into
that of course this first this appeared
in a book by Anthony stamps summers in
late 80s it quoted Susan rosensteil who
was one of the former wives of the head
of Schenley as saying that she went to
two parties at the Plaza Hotel hoover's
there in a red dress having sex with
some young blonde boys there were the
other people present well it just common
sense tells you that could not have
happened at the Plaza Hotel with all
these witnesses present and in not leak
out and it didn't because it didn't
exist it didn't happen
beyond that Suzie Rosen steals record
for credibility is not exactly sterling
in fact she had been convicted of
perjury and in spite of that the press
picked up this claim from this book and
now it's pretty much accepted as as
gospel by most people I also interviewed
agents who were on Hoover security
detail
who would have loved to tell me some
juicy gossip about what they saw but
they said that Hoover would have dinner
almost every night with Clyde Tolson the
Associate Director of the FBI who was
his close friend and they would go to
vacations together but that after dinner
they would follow
Tolson to his apartment drop him off
then they would take Hoover to his house
drop him off they would stay overnight
in front of the house and they never saw
anything happened between the two men
it's always possible given Hoover's
lifestyle he never married he lived as
his mother until the age of 43 that he
was gay and didn't know it or suppressed
it but there was nothing overt
unfortunately in terms of creating some
juicy revelations
after Clarence Kelly got the FBI back
into organized crime and other more
significant complex cases which the FBI
really was was established to go after
and got the FBI away from just compiling
statistics on arrests to impress
Congress which Hoover liked to do for
example he would he would claim credit
for cars recovered by the local police
and then he would show how many
recoveries he made and this was supposed
to impress Congress and of course
meanwhile organized crime was
flourishing because of the fact that
Hoover ignored organized crime he
finally did have to get into organized
crime after the Appalachian meeting
which was 1957 when a state trooper saw
all these mafia people from all over the
country meeting in upstate New York and
also Bobby Kennedy as Attorney General
forced Hoover into becoming more
aggressive in organized crime after
Clarence Kelly William Webster became
director he was a former judge a former
prosecutor and he had no management
experience whatsoever and yet he turned
out to be a fantastic director he has
very smart he had this instinct which
told him that he should let the veterans
seasoned agents manage these very
complex cases but at the same time that
he would he would ask very probing
questions he would demand honesty and it
can be very tough on people if they
screwed up and under Webster basically
the FBI operated flawlessly there was
one problem called Cistus but beyond
that there was no problem whatsoever and
they got really going into into these
complex areas of organized crime
white-collar crime instead of compiling
statistics on how many arrests they made
they would spend years on one case one
white-collar fraud case for example
where hundreds of agents might be
involved one agent might spend three
years in one case and of course the
statistics and arrests would not be very
impressive but this was the kind of
a very difficult very sensitive case
that the FBI should have been working on
after Webster we had William Sessions he
was also a former judge also former
prosecutor everyone thought he would
just be another clone of William Webster
but he turned out to be quite different
in my first FBI book the FBI inside the
world's most powerful law-enforcement
agency which is focused on that time
period sessions in Webster and it came
out in 1993 I was given unprecedented
access to the bureau by sessions based
on recommendations from other agents
under sessions and in the course of
doing that book I learned that sessions
himself was engaging in various abuses
he was using FBI funds to build the
fence around his house he was using the
FBI's plane to go on frequent trips to
San Francisco and other places to see
his daughter to go to Baltimore to the
ballet with his wife and also he gave a
pass to FBI headquarters to his wife
Alice when you have to have a top-secret
security clearance to have such a pass
and so I pursue these allegations very
quietly and established as to establish
them all the while not wanting to stop
my access to the FBI of course at the
very end I finally asked for an
interview with sessions about these
abuses he didn't want to do it I wrote a
letter at the suggestion of a PR person
there outlining these abuses to see if
he would comment or if he would meet
with me unbeknown to me this letter was
turned over by the FBI to the judge
Department for investigation as they're
required to do when there's an
allegation of abuse and that led to
sessions dismissal eventually by William
Clinton when sessions did finally meet
with me he would not respond to the
charges but rather spent a half an hour
just balling me out for looking into
this whole area and especially for
looking into Alice sessions
involvement in the FBI abuses and and
really her her role as co-director of
the FBI sessions never did get it I'm
afraid and he he is the only FBI
director to have been fired after
sessions came when Louis Freeh who
became director in 1993 again he was a
judge he was a former prosecutor at one
thought he would be wonderful there was
this idea that if you're a former judge
you will not engage in the kind of
abuses that Hoover engaged in Louis
Freeh was also a former agent he had
been an agent for six years he had never
supervised the case but it turned out
that he had this attitude that he knew
more than anybody in the FBI about how
to supervise cases and that he spent
much of his time almost all his time in
fact micromanaging a few high-profile
cases it takes tremendous experience to
manage one of these cases and the FBI
had always always worked collegially
they would consult with each other they
would offer honest opinions to each
other and that's why the FBI did quite
well largely until Louis Freeh took over
but Louis Freeh had this attitude that
he knew everything he didn't have to
consult with anybody in fact he would
discourage people from telling him about
problems in cases or from disagreeing
with him roger nicely the head of the
hostage rescue team was a little more
brave than some of the agents and he
would occasionally disagree with free
but he told me that he would preface his
remarks to free by saying permission
requested to be candid sir and free
would grudgingly say well i guess they
don't have any choice this is the way
the FBI was operated and now we wonder
why it seems to be a bunch of bumbling
idiots because the underfur either were
Fiasco's after Fiasco's after Fiasco's
each of the Fiasco's i traced in my book
back to louie fries decisions
it shouldn't be surprising that when
someone is the head of an agency for
eight years that of course they would be
responsible just the way the CEO
loosened or Enron was responsible for
their problems and in turn Jack Welch is
credited with with the fact that GE is
managed so well but beyond that free
made these decisions that seriously
damage the FBI one was he substantially
slashed the headquarters personnel which
consisted mainly of supervisors and
laboratory personnel he had this New
York Asians mentality which is that
headquarters is the enemy enemy so even
if he promoted a supervisor or a special
agent in charge he still would undercut
that person would not trust him and so
as a result of this slash in
headquarters there were very few
experienced supervisors left to manage
many of the cases and especially for
example in Chinese counterintelligence
and that is why the Wynn wholly case was
so screwed up now others talk because of
Colleen rally's recent letter that field
agents know everything and headquarters
is always the enemy well of course it's
the truth is in between and indicate in
the way Noli case it was the other way
around there was the field agents who
screwed up because there were no
experienced headquarters personnel to
supervise this very sensitive case the
same thing happened in laboratory the
laboratory was slashed so drastically by
free that cases were were backlogged
that there were a lot of errors the head
of the laboratory John Hicks warned free
that if he slashes headquarters to such
a great degree that this exact problem
would occur free ignored him John Hicks
resigned and of course we heard later
about the scandal involving the
laboratory the region jewel case again
goes back to Louis Freeh the fact that
Jill was one of dozens and dozens of
possible suspects
leaked out there was some 600
law-enforcement people who were aware
that he was a suspect so we don't know
if this came from the FBI or others but
the FBI wanted to interview him wanted
to see if they could just clear up some
of the questions if they could they
would leave him alone he volunteer
voluntarily came to the field office in
the middle of the interview Lois
recalled from Washington and said read
him his rights well anybody even a new
graduate out of the FBI's Academy at
Quantico
knows that you don't have to read
Miranda rights unless someone has has
been arrested or is about to be arrested
and neither was true with Richard Jewell
the special agent in charge in Atlanta
said there's no need to read him his
rights free said now read him his rights
even the US attorney in Atlanta who was
there on this conference call said there
was no need to read him his rights and
the FBI deputy director who was with
free Weldon Bear Bryant told free there
was no need again for he ignored the
advice he said read him his rights as
soon as they read him his rights Richard
Jewell clammed up as for an attorney so
the result wasn't this whole thing
dragged on for months because the FBI
could not clear up these issues with
with Jewell on a voluntary basis and had
to instead investigate him much more
thoroughly and that led to this huge
scandal involving the Richard Jewell
case another black eye for the FBI again
going back to Louis Freeh Louis Freeh
blamed the agents
it wasn't until some nine months later
that he finally admitted in
congressional testimony that he had
given this warning and at that point he
he tried to blame it on others his his
whole approaches has always been to
claim that he takes responsibility and
then blame others the more recent
McVeigh case where the FBI did not turn
over documents again goes back to Louis
Freese decisions because the reason that
those documents was were not turned over
is that the FBI's computer system was
such a wreck that it
keep track of all the documents a lot of
material would be missing when this
computer system was first installed in
1993 1995 it had 1980s technology Louis
Freeh was told at the time this is a
wreck it can't be used agents you know
have tremendous trouble using it there
are all these other problems again he
ignored it and just went ahead and had
it installed free himself did not use
email the first thing he did when he
became FBI director is order the
computer in his office taken out and
that tells you a lot about his attitudes
the FBI's computers because of free
until just a few months ago we're
literally 386 and 46 machines that
nobody would even take as a donation to
a church and yet this is what the FBI
was trying to use to keep track of
terrorists they didn't have cd-roms they
didn't have medicines when they had to
send a photo of a suspect to another
office they would send it to an agent's
home computer or to police station
because the graphic could not be
downloaded in the FBI this is how I
rageous the situation was in fact even
worse about a year and a half ago the
FBI actually did not have enough money
for gasoline for its cars and for about
four months half the cars are parked
again because of Louis Freeh his
mismanagement now you have to ask how he
seemed to have escaped criticism for
eight years and one one last fiasco that
goes back to free is the Robert Hansen
case even though Hansen stopped spy
started spying before he took over in
1994 after the Aldrich Ames case Bear
Bryant who was over Counter Intelligence
in the FBI recommended to free that they
polygraph all agents again free ignored
the advice if he had adopted that advice
and started polygraph e there's no
question in my mind that Hansen would
have stopped his spine just because of
the deterrent effect he was no fool and
in the fact in the past he had in fact
stops by and when he feared that he
might
be calm so how did pre escape criticism
except for a few items in the press
including two op-ed pieces that I did in
the Washington Post the last saying
fire-free first of all he was very good
at manipulating Congress when the
Democrats were in power before what when
he first took over he would emphasize
issues that they like like minority
hiren which is a wonderful legitimate
issue but this made him a hero to the
Democrats when the Republicans took over
he would emphasize his just days for
Bill Clinton he would leap material
including the memo that he wrote
opposing Janet Reno's position on the
independent council and that made him
the darling of the Republicans he had an
aide by the nabob Bucknam who was chief
of staff who would be in charge of
leaking these things and of course free
would take disciplinary action against
the agents who leaked material but Bob
Bucknam was never polygraphed over
leaking even though everyone in the
bureau knew he was leaking and the
Deputy Attorney General Jamie Garelick
in fact discovered evidence from her
media sources that he was leaking but
beyond that it's still a mystery to me
even today some people such as a Wall
Street Journal editorial board are
calling for the resignation of Bob
Muller who took over a week before
September 11th knew nothing about what
happened in the FBI before that
certainly knew nothing about this
problem between the Minneapolis agents
and their supervisor in headquarters and
yet they are saying he should resign
well the real culprit is not there and I
guess people want to have an easy
scapegoat the person who is now in
charge but the fact is all these
problems go back to free including a
risk-averse atmosphere in headquarters
which I think contributed to the fact
that the supervisor in headquarters did
not give Coleen Rowley the support that
she should have had in getting a
successful application to search
misawa's computer
because free would cut off the heads of
managers over very minor issues often
not knowing the facts many of them just
hunker down and figured that it was
better to do nothing than to do
something with that said I think it's
important to keep in mind that even and
we're jumping ahead to the current
situation even if all these dots have
been connected and they certainly should
have been the Phoenix memo which was a
theory a hunch
the Missouri information and other
information that information by itself
would not have uncovered the plot of
September 11th that information might
have led to more suspicion more
investigations which conceivably could
have been covered the plot that's why
Muller is said it might have uncovered
it it's there are a lot of semantics
involved here the real way to uncover
al-qaeda's plotting is to penetrate that
organization which is primarily the
responsibility of the CIA and
secondarily in the u.s. of the FBI and
that is something that they are we're
working on of course much more than
before the CIA did have some assets as
they call them in al-qaeda but they were
not at a high enough level in the inner
circle to detect - to report on what was
going on and don't forget there was a 25
million-dollar reward on on bin Laden's
head and nobody turned a man it's very
hard to penetrate these organizations
but it is possible and I think now all
of American ingenuity and might has been
is being focused on that on that issue
in the book I reveal Louis freeze
mismanagement which really in many cases
was much more disastrous than the abuses
that William sessions engaged in based
in large part on on the record
interviews with many of the people whom
he promoted including many of his
deputy directors and of course the
question is how do I get this kind of
access given the fact that I have been
critical of the FBI before that my
previous book led to the sessions
dismissal and I think the answer is in
part that the agents first of all think
that I know I probably know a lot anyway
I think they feel that I'll be fair even
I would even though reveal abuses in the
warts that in the end I will I do have
respect for the agents in the FBI I
think they're very dedicated talented
and the problem over the years has been
leadership from Jagger Hoover to Louis
Freeh I also am a little careful about
revealing things that should not be
revealed for example if I knew of an
ongoing investigation or a defector who
might be jeopardized then I would not
use that information I think that's
something that any responsible
journalist would do in my first book on
the FBI in 1993 I revealed that Visalli
Metropia had defected to the US and was
and had provided information on hundreds
of spy operations over the years but I
knew that he had already come to the
u.s. he was not a defector in place as
they call it someone who still was in
the Soviet Union he was he was now safe
however the FBI initiated a leak
investigation after that disclosure and
I heard beforehand that they were going
to try to interview me of course they
knew that I wasn't going to tell them
anything but that was just the procedure
that they had to go through so I went
through in my mind how I was going to
greet these agents and what I would do
when they came I would welcome them I
would give them coffee I just moved them
I try to develop them as sources but of
course I wouldn't tell them anything and
I've always thought that I could tell
FBI agents having worked with so many
for so many years and
having many friends who were agents and
very few people knock on my door in
Potomac so a few days later there was a
ring on the bell ring at the Bell at the
door
and I opened the door and there were
these two very sort of clean-cut men
wearing conservative suits and thin ties
and looking and sort of like someone
like zealots and I said I know who you
guys are come on in and they sort of
looked at me and they offered these
magazines it was the watchtower
yeah and I think they were more scared
of me than than I was scared of them so
Bob Muller came in and I got my I got
the first interview with Muller
this was after basically this new book
had been written I decided to write this
new book the bureau of the secret
history of the FBI because I I thought
that telling the whole story of FBI
would be a much more interesting
approach than my previous book beginning
with 1908 bringing the right through to
the present going through the Hoover
years but also telling the inside story
and the secrets and I was able to
interview of course a lot of the people
who worked with Muller as he came into
office one person was the computer guru
at the FBI who had finally been hired by
free at the very end when it was really
too late I mean everything was a wreck
they had 93 million pages of documents
on counterterrorism alone going back ten
years and none of it was on computer if
it was it was in this primitive system
where you can put in flight schools and
not come up with anything because there
was no retrieval system and this the
computer person said that
a few weeks before Muller took office he
came into his office and it so happens
the mother is very technologically
oriented in fact everything that free
did wrong Muller in my opinion is doing
right and one of that one of those areas
is is upgrading the computers and the
computers person discussed with Muller
what he would have on his computer and
Muller said well I'd like to have
Microsoft Word I'd like to have a few
other standard pieces of software and
the computers person says well I can put
on your machine but it won't work with
anything in the FBI and Muller was just
stunned he actually ordered the
development of a software program that's
now used by US attorneys because he was
a former US attorney and a former former
head of the just Department Criminal
Division which is now used throughout
the country by US Attorney's so Muller
actually we as soon as he came in before
our September 11th excuse me started
ordering the upgrading of the FBI's
computers ordering thousands of new Dell
computers or at least they'll be up to
the standards of our home computers
started increased in analysis I mean he
was almost clairvoyant now in retrospect
because of the kinds of changes that he
was making back then that now are so
obviously needed I interviewed people he
had seen at Quantico the FBI Academy
before September 11th and they said he
was he wanted courses in analysis he
wanted courses in data mining all these
things that Louis Freeh you know didn't
even didn't even know the definition of
and again data mining of course is so
important when it comes to keeping track
of all this information keeping all
these dots together and making some
sense of it and so September 11th
occurred as we know
and again the computers came into play
because they were following leads they
were sending out agents to interview
people and because of these primitive
computers which could not be trusted or
and they had to download them from one
thing to another thing was unbelievable
they would in addition to using the
computers they would call their fax so a
lot of times three teams of agents were
sent out tend to be one person when only
one team should have been said and these
people were needed of course because
again of the computers in other cases
some people were not interviewed because
of these problems
just just scandalous the the latest
criticisms of course are very valid
there's a tremendous need for the FBI to
exchange information with other agencies
exchange information within the FBI
before September 11th the FBI was
totally overloaded when it came to
terrorism which isn't to say that it was
totally useless the fact is the FBI did
stop some 40 terrorist plots in the past
five or six years including the plot to
blow up the tunnels around Manhattan but
they the information tended to come from
informants or from intercepts as opposed
to this additional layer of information
where you look beyond your media sources
you look beyond your penetrations and
you just try to make sense of all the
information out there and come up with
good theories and good hunches to
conduct investigations so the that is a
crucial new element that the FBI has to
engage in and is with with this increase
in analysts with this increase in
terrorism agents that Muller has
announced the increase in terrorism
agents is some 600 which to me is
nothing now after the increase there'll
be roughly 2,500 foreign
counterterrorism agents
that compares with 40,000 police
officers in New York City alone and to
me I would not be at all unhappy if the
FBI's budget and agents were doubled
there's talk about cutting back in
certain areas of crime of criminal
activity in order to focus more on
counterterrorism we should have both we
should have a tremendous
counterterrorism force and we should
also be able to go after organized crime
white-collar crime political corruption
espionage all the other areas that the
FBI is responsible for the total budget
of the FBI is about to be four billion
dollars including a secret component for
Counter Intelligence that compares to
one or two stealth bombers is nothing
compared to the Defense Department
budget I you know think that they should
double the size the FBI and we would get
a lot more safety out of it the new
guidelines which allows the FBI more
freedom to do what the rest of us do
namely to walk into a mosque or a
synagogue or a church to surf the net to
use data mining is in my opinion a
reasonable change I understand why
people are concerned because it sounds
like the Hoover days because Hoover
would collect the information from
public gatherings for the purpose of
stifling political dissent because he
would keep this information and files
and and use it in Likud and he would
also of course engage in other intrusive
techniques keeping files on people for
blackmail purposes but the difference is
the use and you can misuse anything in
the FBI agents have guns agents can make
arrests we trust them to do that they
can misuse it if they do we have to take
action but that doesn't mean that we
want them to be powerless and not have
gotten
not make arrests and by the same token
we need them to protect our safety
it seems that on the one hand people are
criticizing the FBI for not knowing
enough and at the same time they're
criticizing the FBI for wanting to know
too much and there's even this strange
reasoning by the ACLU that
well the FBI screwed up so why reward
them by giving them more power as if
this is an errant child that needs to be
punished and deprived of its of being
allowed to drive at night this is not
the way we're going to protect our
security we are in a war it doesn't look
it but the fact is they're out there
plotting to to destroy us and we need to
take action not to break laws not to
tear up the Constitution but to do what
the rest of us do which is to be able to
walk into a public place and for the FBI
to use that information for the purpose
of trying to target criminal activity
the FBI has no interest today in
people's political beliefs they have
enough to do believe me with with what
they're doing now just trying to stop
terrorism now which isn't to say that
the FBI cannot go off course and
certainly can again with another
director perhaps with another president
perhaps there are always possibilities
for abuse but if that happens then we
have to take action we have to prosecute
the people responsible have more
oversight perhaps pass more laws the
fact is that the FBI today is of course
very different from the old days now
there is oversight under who where there
is no oversight essentially by Congress
and and it's a different world in those
days there was no Freedom of Information
Act which allowed people to know what
the FBI is doing they we didn't even
know what they were doing and of course
today we have much more aggressive press
but it is important to
remain within law and my experience the
FBI understands that in fact they have
not violated the law as an organization
since the Hoover days and there really
is no track record which would suggest
that the FBI would would start abusing
individual rights let's see what other
little points
the FBI is very good at creating its own
image certainly under Hoover it was a
master at that and the FBI was portrayed
as never doing wrong its agents always
got its man Hoover was portrayed as as a
great patriotic leader who even would
would have people like book halter and
other gangland figures turn themselves
into him these were all made-up stories
the fact is that never happen and is
hard to penetrate the FBI and find out
what really goes on behind the scenes
the one people talk about the FBI
culture as being involved with for some
of these problems I don't see that I you
saw that the Phoenix agent and the
Minneapolis agents were very much on top
of things
very aggressive there was the problem in
headquarters with with risk adversity I
would call it a risk averseness but the
one cultural problem I do see is that a
small minority of Asians and
particularly former agents have this
very self protective attitude Hoover
used to say don't embarrass the bureau
and they've taken all that to heart and
that kind of attitude leads to some of
the cover-ups that have occurred some of
the problems that have occurred within
the Society of former agents there's a
small group over fifty about 1,500
former agents known as the XG boys and
they are people who subscribe to a
what's called a listserv where they
write email messages in and then this
just listserv distributes it back to the
to the people who are signed up to the
listserv and I was able to monitor those
communications all legally of course and
it was it was rather pathetic and I
quoted some of them in the book they
simply would support the FBI no matter
what they were denounced anybody who
would Kris as the FBI
including former very respected FBI
officials like buck Ravel and this
attitude is is is the one cultural
problem I see but it only applies to
minority of agents and former agents the
majority of them are very smart very
sophisticated and understand that of
course in a free society we have to
criticize the bureau and get these these
problems rectified I am very confident
that Bob mother will rectify the
problems he has a sense of urgency about
him he's very demanding as a former
Marine a few months ago the head of
counterintelligence Sheila Koran briefed
him on a case and did not reveal the
problems in a kit in the case and he
learned about these problems and he
removed her banister that was exactly
the opposite of what Louis Freeh would
have done Louis Freeh in fact banished
people for telling him the problems and
that really is the bottom line on why I
feel confident that the bureau is now in
good hands because the previous attitude
is one that simply corrupted all the
deliberative processes of the FBI how
can you make honest decisions and good
decisions if nobody tells the truth and
it's very easy for people on the outside
to say it's the cultural problem you
know the agency is a wreck the agents
are all bad because they don't know what
really goes on inside and when you do
gut get into the inside and find out how
these things happen how the decisions
were made you find out that it goes back
to one man and that's not very
surprising as I mentioned before you in
when it comes to publicly held companies
we all understand that the CEO is
responsible when there's when there are
major problems and that is was the case
with Louis Freeh I would like to take
your questions and I hope you're not too
hungry for a roast beef sandwich after I
started that story yes J Edgar Hoover
a man who had many many deficiencies of
course and one of them allegedly
allegedly was thing
and he used to like to go to the
racetrack and the Meyer Lansky and you
know people like that the Mafia type
people would place bets for him and if
the horses would win they would give him
the tickets and he would go cash them in
but if the horses would lose they
wouldn't ask him for the money for that
they used to place the bet do you have
any idea whether this is true and also
just generally what what is your theory
as to why he he never went after the
Mafia the question is whether Hoover
engaged in corruption with with racing
and organized crime
I did hear those rumors and I did look
into them and I was not able to verify
them I doubt if they're true Hoover
would go to the racetrack in a regular
basis he would bet much higher amounts
than he then he led on he would claim
him it made $2 bets but he would send
agents around quietly to make
hundred-dollar bets the theory that
Meyer Lansky and organized crime held
this over him or held over him some
homosexual activities appeared mainly in
this book by Anthony summers and one
fatal flaw with the theory was that
after Hoover was forced into going it
into organized crime and I believe he
didn't before because he just was afraid
of the organized crime might topple him
the same way he was afraid of going
after politicians or congressmen he was
most of all concerned about keeping his
job but after he was forced into going
into organized crime by Bobby Kennedy
who became Attorney General then he was
very aggressive and I have memos that I
cite in the book from Hoover saying
Meyer Lansky has to be investigated
aggressively you know and and some
excuse of the field office offered for
not putting in a wiretap was not
acceptable go investigate him well if he
had all this blackmail material on on
Hoover obviously Hoover would not have
been
making those demands yes
simple question are there any term
limits to the director after Hoover died
in 1972 Congress imposed a 10 year limit
on the term of an FBI director and the
purpose was to avoid another jeger
Hoover that doesn't mean that the
director cannot be fired in the interim
or of course resign but it but by
tradition the president's have not
replaced FBI directors when they were
elected and the only situation where
there was a firing was was Bill Clinton
the idea is to keep this position
non-political and I think it's
interesting that after Hoover died there
were all these all these great peons of
praise for members of Congress for
Hoover but as soon as the funeral is
over all of a sudden they they started
learning about all the abuses looking
into them finding out how he had kept
files on them in fact I did store the
Washington Post which revealed some of
that and and it was the same as Louis
Freeh you know during Louie fries tenure
Congress just thought it was wonderful
when he when he resigned many members of
Congress that he was the best FBI
director ever and now of course they
recognized that most the problems that
we now see were traceable to Louis Freeh
so Congress certainly bears some of the
blame for the situation we're in now yes
host some days ago report
on the FBI's another large divestment in
a brothel in New Orleans as a part of a
sting operation yeah well 13 months 10
agents 9 prior to 9/11 and subsequent to
9/11 was suggestive a existence of a
fairly deep cultural problem i don't
know you know i it does sound like there
was a lot of effort to expand that on a
brothel and these these investigations
are approved on different levels
including the Justice Department the
local US Attorney so it's not all the
FBI is not it's not necessarily a
cultural problem but I think that's
that's a valid point yes yes I had a
really difficult to believe that red
flag wasn't raised agent Williams for
Phoenix Rowley from Minnesota send memos
and then one of the memos from Raleigh
was faltered
and they didn't pursue that do I
understand that maybe these little
mental management agents were afraid to
go to Louie's fries and say we've got a
real problem here we needed rezident
because of being reprimanded or the
question is about the Phoenix in
annapolis situations in the Phoenix
situation the agent was proposing to
interview a lot of Middle Eastern men
because they were going to fly schools
it was a very good hunch
in retrospect but imagine the outcry of
the FBI back then before September 11
started interviewing a huge number of
Middle Eastern men even after September
11th when the FBI wanted to interview
5,000 Middle Easterners there were some
protests before September 11th I really
think that would not have been feasible
and even if they had done that it would
not have uncovered the plot but still
that information should have been
brought together should have been
analyzed should have been used to
develop more leads more investigation
more of a focus and in Minneapolis as I
said before I do think that the agent
rally was absolutely correct that the
supervisor should have worked to get
enough to get a successful application
to search most hours computer that is
even though there was no direct sign of
a connection between Masami and a
terrorist group or foreign country which
you need to have to get such an
application there was enough
circumstantial evidence that could have
been cited that would have indicated
that he probably was part of a group and
therefore that would have been approved
even when after they looked at the
computer keep in mind after September
11th there was nothing really there that
there was a flight simulator program and
there was a crop dusting information
which could or could not be ominous but
nothing actually tying him to the plot
but again that whole attitude was wrong
and I do think that risk-averse
atmosphere that existed in headquarters
goes back to Louis Freeh there was a
political correctness that he
posed and there was a fear of of making
decisions that might possibly lead to
criticism and and that was a very
damaging part of his legacy yes looking
into your crystal ball the long-term
impact of Ashbaugh
I think that Ashcraft in many ways is
doing the right thing is turning the FBI
towards more towards prevention that
doesn't mean they're not going to do
investigations the leads of prosecutions
of course I think he was wrong and some
of some other areas such as the idea of
having Middle Easterners interviewed
mainly by police and and non FBI people
simply has sort of a fishing expedition
that didn't make much sense at all and I
gather led to very little useful
information if any but and there's also
the criticism that Muller is too close
to Ashcroft Ashcroft appointed or urged
the appointment of Muller of course I
think that Muller does disagree with
Ashcroft in private and has tried to
create the appearance that he's not just
a puppet of Ashcroft which is what what
it looked like in the beginning they
were sort of marching together all all
the time and and and always be together
but that is a problem you don't want to
have the FBI director appear to be too
close to either the Attorney General or
the president because there is a
political aspect to being Attorney
General or president yes main and we're
presently absolved
about the reason calls for relaxing of
restrictions on the bureau in that
respect well I did talk about the the
effort to relax the restrictions that I
think that the restrictions were silly I
mean I in the book before which came out
before these new guidelines I said that
it's crazy that agents can't walk into a
mosque or a synagogue which is open to
anybody else that they actually would
would stop at the at the door of a
mosque when they were following someone
that's crazy because a lot of these
plots are in fact hatched in mosques and
also that in many cases they had to
already know that a crime had been
committed before they could start an
investigation in other words someone had
to come in to tell them an informant or
somebody else would have to bring
someone to their attention as opposed to
they're going out and looking for clues
themselves which might include looking
at a chatroom
which is open to the public where
terrorism is discussed bomb-making is
discussed if you or I can look at that
why shouldn't the FBI look at that
that's not you know it's very very very
damaging to to allowing the FBI to stop
terrorism in the in the future it's so
easy to you know forget about September
11th and you know everything seems safe
right now but you know tomorrow there
could be another major attack and and we
have to have the FBI on our side not on
their side not on the side of someone
who you know raises all these frivolous
concerns that doesn't mean that we want
them to break the law or break the
Constitution absolutely not and there's
a fine line as a fine balance between
good law enforcement and violating
rights Django Hoover certainly broke
that in many many ways but he's been
dead for 30 years
let's let's move on yes
foresman agency
get guy
when you interview for the writing could
you talk to any assistant directors that
that says Claire who's lost that man the
grease needle won that battle that they
wish that did they didn't have drug
jurisdiction that the FBI primary drug
sure huh yeah uh now generally the FBI
people seem satisfied with with the drug
jurisdiction they the thinking now is
that the FBI should just be involved in
drug investigations where there's some
additional concern like political
corruption maybe some other criminal
activity as well and that the rest of
the drug investigations should be
handled by DEA and that makes sense and
and the same with bank robberies there's
no need for the FBI to be involved in
every bank robbery there should be local
police who handle a Dominican many
cities it has done that way and there's
also you know the Joint Terrorism Task
Forces between local police and the FBI
in about thirty five cities where they
do cooperate and there of course there
have been instances of lack of
cooperation but overall they actually do
cooperate in most in most cities yes
my opinion is wanting to investigate its
own failure to provide adequate
oversight
I think that the present investigation
by the joint intelligence committees is
sufficient by the intelligence
communities working together that we
really need the FBI NCI to work on
stopping the next attack and it doesn't
mean we want to cover up what happened
before we need to learn what happened
before but I think the current
investigation is going to provide that
information you know it's very obvious
at this point what needs to be done and
what is being done there has to be a
seamless real-time sharing of
information between the FBI and CIA they
did cooperate before especially since
George Tenet took over in 1937 they did
have FBI agents assigned to the CIA and
vice versa but there wasn't this just
constant seamless sharing of information
and one raising again was the FBI's
computers they literally did not have
email between FBI and CIA because of
Louis Freeh but but they are working on
that I think that's going to change yes
freedom I mean places of worship they
call it places of worship but let's face
the worst boss of the old
citizens America Muslims can decode pray
I mean the weird looking spied on us to
mark you know when the FBI started going
after the Ku Klux Klan which they had
not done initially because whoever
didn't want to but eventually he was
forced into it they did profiling then
they look for the white man and war
she's you know and that's what we're
looking for here when it turns out that
Jews are involved in terrorism as I have
been there was the American Jewish
Defense League some years ago that in
fact was involved in terrorism and was
prosecuted then believe me the FBI will
go after them and it's not just mosques
that that in some cases the FBI will be
looking at and in fact some of these
plotters in the September 11th plot
didn't go to mosque you know maybe
someone that will even think of going in
churches is to cover up what they're
doing who knows but but the point is
when something is public there's simply
no reason why the FBI should not be able
to go there
if the FBI misuses its power and and
starts using this information for some
nefarious purpose as was done under
Hoover then of course we have to take
action but let's wait until that happens
let's not try to anticipate all the
problems that might arise the the
frequent argument is well this is just
the first step next thing you know
they'll be doing such and such well it's
the same with the fact that that FBI
agents are allowed to carry guns you
know it's just the first step they're
carrying guns the next thing you know
they'll be they'll be shooting all of us
you know let's get a little common sense
into this and and recognize that we need
the FBI to protect us and we have a
system of laws that does allow us to
take action against an agency if it does
violate rights not to mention civil
remedy remedies and if those abuses
occur I think that they will be dealt
with yes
mentioned all the computer problems they
attributed primarily to freeze attitude
but it seems that agency like the FBI
had basic Parker's job has always been
to gather a manager large amount of
information and organization as old as
the FBI should've had systems in place
which may not have been modernized as
fast as they could have been just
wondering if there must be other factors
I have heard that the Hoover actually
has good reputation early on from his
career managing data at the time with
the tools available and free computer
age well Hoover did have a very good
system of indexing of course it was all
on paper and but those cases were not
the kind of massive massive cases that
the FBI tackles today where they need to
know everything about global terrorism
even in organized crime or white-collar
crime there massive amounts of
information they might issue a thousand
subpoenas and of course to do that you
need computers the FBI is a quasi
military organization very very
responsive to the director and if the
director doesn't want computers you know
they're not going to get computers and
Congress isn't going to give them
computers unless the director asks for
it and if unless Congress thinks that
the FBI knows how to use computers which
is another issue they have and
eventually the Congress didn't want to
give more money because they felt that
the FBI didn't even know what it wanted
or how to get it or where was going
because it was so screwed up in the
computer area it's the funny thing the
way people try to blame you know this
amorphous mass the whole agency all the
agents you know the culture let's split
it up let's let's start a new agency
it's very simple you know in your own
organization in your own company
you realize that the boss has a
tremendous amount of power of what
happens and certainly if the boss is
there for eight years as Louis Freeh was
he has an incredible impact and it's
very simple the people under free whom I
interviewed who were quoted in the book
on the record described how they would
try to convince him of different things
there were few in the inner circle who
were able to sometimes present him with
a few ideas almost everybody else was
banished for doing that and they were
rebuffed and it was very very sad
situation yes
yes now Robert Muller who is very
computer savvy has ordered thousands and
thousands of the new Dell computers
they're upgrading all kinds of other
systems as well just trying to you know
quickly quickly get up to the speed of
our home computers it's unbelievable you
know just totally totally essentially
criminally negligent behavior by by by
Louis frame yes did you but did you
interview me your local prosecutor out
in Idaho Ruby Ridge
the Sharpshooter was indicted no but
that's a very important question of
course about Waco and where we Ridge
which both of which occurred before
Louis Freeh took over when William
sessions was director neither was the
horrible horrible situation that has
been portrayed by many people the right
wing will claim that the FBI purposely
went out and murdered and everybody at
Waco and purposely murdered Vicki Weaver
at Ruby Ridge both were tragedies both
should not have happened but there were
honest mistakes in the case of Waco the
FBI thought that the way to get these
Branch Davidians out and they were
engaging a child's to child abuse was to
throw tear gas in there and they would
come out there were a few profilers who
said they might possibly commit suicide
most of them said no they wouldn't
retrospect the ones who said they might
commit suicide were right in retrospect
the FBI should have waited should have
just left them alone and that was a
tragic mistake
in the case of Ruby Ridge the agent Lana
Ruchi thought he was firing at Randy
Weaver they've been involved in a
previous incident with the marshals
where Marshall was killed instead Vicki
Weaver opened the door of this cabin
just as he was shooting and the bullet
went through her by mistake there was
also a cover-up after that over the fact
that there was an expansion of FBI
deadly force policies which didn't
contribute to the shooting but shouldn't
have happened the cover-up shouldn't
have happened
Louis Freeh however used this as one of
his tools for making himself look better
he would denounce Ruby Ridge in Waco he
would not let the agents give their side
which would have presented a more
balanced perspective and really he would
use the FBI as sort of a whipping boy to
enhance his own image and and that
contributed to the fact that the FBI is
now known as a bunch of bumblers the
fact that these Fiasco's occurred of
course is part of that as well
but that is what happened in Waco and
Ruby Ridge yes yeah I did not know I
went over the material you know a lot of
written material a lot of intv the FBI
agents and and I think that I presented
an accurate story what happened there
you know it's unfortunate that they've
been all these conspiracy theories
peoples you know I've presented a film
that shows some sunlight glinting off a
piece of metal and they claim that there
was FBI agents shooting at the people in
the compound when the fact is that the
FBI tried to save some of those people
they were on fire
and the agents would run after them and
try to get them out they would run back
into the compound and it was it was a
very tragic situation the whole thing
was on CNN live we all saw it and there
was you know nobody saw any FBI agents
tooting on anybody or any of these other
conspiracies yes sanity for the Maya
went holy cakes
and it just came down to a terrible
supervision by headquarters and there
was one mishap after another bye-bye the
field agents and there's no question
that when Olli violated security
procedures on a wholesale basis
downloaded all this secret information
that he would meet with Chinese overseas
and not report those meetings as he
should have but whether he was actually
spy we don't know there's no besides
this group of the investigation Louis
Freeh approved the indictment of when le
which he shouldn't have done I mean
there was no there was not sufficient
evidence and prior to free taking over
the FBI did a wonderful job of espionage
investigations in one year 1985 they had
11 major spy cases Jonathan Pollard John
Walker
they all went down smoothly they all
pleaded guilty there was no claim of
improper conduct and that reputation is
now is now tarnished yes and any
possible investigations who the Oklahoma
City bombing that another person
who after the bomb went to work
Boston Airport
investigation any follow-up the way the
idea started that there was another
person involved with McVeigh was that
when McVeigh rented the truck at writer
I think one of the people at writer
thought that McVeigh seemed to be with
someone else another person didn't think
so and that's how that started and you
know I think it was just a misimpression
McVeigh himself admitted that he did it
and didn't have anybody conspiring with
him I think you know eyewitness
testimony is just the worst thing I
almost I almost think it shouldn't be
used at all you know because in so many
cases it's turned out to be wrong we've
seen with DNA evidence so many times
people have gone to jail for no reason
because of faulty eyewitness accounts
and speaking of going to jail for no
reason one of Hoover's greatest abuses
was that he was told by agents in Boston
that four men were going to jail in
Boston and they were innocent but rather
than do anything about it he wanted to
develop more mafia informants and and
the idea was them out this is going to
help develop more mafia informants if if
they just let let that happen that was
war one of the biggest disgrace is in
FBI history yes cars too
when he passed away what happened to all
of his records have bianket in their
courage and really or are they stashed
away from place what happened to hoover
his records when he died Hoover had
besides files in the general files which
had damaging information on people he
had what were called the official and
confidential files and there was another
category and he had instructed his
assistant Helen Gandy that when he died
she was to destroy these files and
that's what she did she had them
shredded except that there were
exceptions for first unknown reasons and
and a portion of these files were not
shredded so some of them still exist I
was able to quote from some of them in
my book and they tell us the story of
what kind of material he had it was you
know this congressman is sleeping with
this assistant and and Johnston is is
having an affair with so-and-so and that
sort of thing anything that could be
politically politically damaging or
embarrassing that that Hoover could
could hold over the heads of these
people Hoover in many ways was more more
powerful than the presidents I mean he
was in office for forty-eight years he
was better known than any president
admit to most Americans and he had this
incredible power and basically the
presidents reported to him because
because the power that he wielded turns
43 years
and everyone was afraid it might hard to
it's hard to imagine you know but the
fact is that everyone was afraid that he
might have something on them or did have
something on them and nobody would take
him on nobody I mean you know in the
book I quoted attorneys generalists and
you know you can take on anybody but not
Hoover not her you know he was
sacrosanct it is an amazing aspect of of
US history yes in light of the problems
that you've highlighted during free
reign how long you think it's going to
be before the Bureau
where they can be right now how
well-prepared early right now a deal
with Internet
they're much better equipped to deal
with international terrorism now I mean
first of all just the human reaction
that all of us are more suspicious are
more alert and certainly FBI agents are
but secondly free of sorry Muller again
as soon as he took over started having
all of these 93 million pages of
counterterrorism documents put on
computer so at least they're going to
have you know a good database of
information he Muller has created a
great sense of urgency you know he wants
to answers right away he wants action
taken right away and most important as I
said was just this this honest attitude
that he's brought to two investigations
and two deliberations I think all of
that makes a huge difference immediately
in how the FBI operates it's amazing
how sensitive this organization is to
the director and if they understand that
the director will not put up with any
nonsense and will banish you if you tell
if you don't tell about problems then
just like that is going to change it
really is you know it's going to take
more time to to update the technology to
get in place these flying squads from
headquarters which is another good idea
because it will have created
institutional memory in these agents
before there was this constant turnover
of people in headquarters in terrorism
as opposed to espionage with where
people would stay for a long time so
people didn't you know remember what
happened in 1993 when the first World
Trade Center was attacked I think that's
a good idea as well as the idea to allow
field offices to initiate investigations
on their own without going through
headquarters that's the opposite attack
to make to make the FBI more nimble
Muller has this this management skill
which we saw when he was US Attorney in
San Francisco and a head of the Criminal
Division of just Department where he
would shape up
and agency and rectify problems and you
know it creates a lot of grumbling there
is a lot of grumbling among many agents
who just don't like change in my opinion
there is grumbling under William Webster
who was the best director and maybe
Muller would be better but that's the
way it is in organizations when when the
new guy comes in and he makes changes
but so far I think everyone every
changes in the right direction and you
know and the fact that the Wall Street
Journal the color for his resignation is
just is just lunacy you know and it's
just the most it's essentially like
McCarthyism you know where I interviewed
the person who who tell me the source of
the McCarthy's charge that there 205
communist in the State Department Walton
Chauhan the head of the Chicago Tribune
Bureau told me that one of his reporters
came to him after McCarthy made this
initial charges and was was horrified
because he said McCarthy got the 205
figure from him and it was just a rumor
in the State Department he even know who
told it to him and that was the basis of
McCarthy's whole witch-hunt against
communism and and to say that that
Muller who took over a week before
September 11th is you know should resign
because of September 11th and because
the things that he supposedly should
have known about what happened to Mars
earlier between Minneapolis and a
supervisor is just totally nuts
well let's see yes
the directors appointed by the president
but in medicine rigidly disease
report to the attorney yeah the director
reports to the Attorney General but he
also understands or should I understand
I think he does understand that he has
to be independent in some ways that is
it could be that the FBI will start
investigating the Attorney General as
has happened before with John Mitchell
it could be the FBI would start
investigating the president as it did
with Clinton and with Nixon and the FBI
did do a very good impartial job on
those investigations but for that reason
the director has to maintain some
distance from the political leaders and
speaking of Nixon and Watergate I reveal
in my book some new information about
who deep throat might be I don't claim
to absolutely know but I think it's
interesting information about a year and
a half ago Bob Woodward showed up at the
home of Mark felt who has long been
remembered as one of the candidates to
be deep throat he was associate FBI
director during Watergate he was
actually in charge of the Watergate
investigation
and so on a daily basis he saw all the
reports knew all the information he
would have been a wonderful source and
the and what Vernon Bernstein did in
fact have information from FBI reports
but Woodward showed up unexpectedly
unannounced he apparently came in a
white limousine which he parked a few
blocks away and Mark field was then
being taken care of by his daughter Joan
because he had two strokes he had
dementia he's very confused because of
these drugs and in spite of that
Woodward not only met with him but took
him to lunch they had a martini and it
seemed like a big celebration according
to John fell now why would Bob Woodward
as was quite a few other things to do
meet with someone go out to lunch with
him if he had dementia if he were a
family member or a close friend that
would certainly be understandable and
expected but otherwise the only
explanation I see is that they were
having a little celebration over the
that would word and had used mark felt
as his source and that he was in fact
Eve throat I'll leave that to you to
speculate upon and I'm sure we'll get
the answer someday well thank you I
really enjoyed your questions
I appreciate Ronald Kessler is author of
the life insurance game Spy vs spy and
inside the CIA his latest the bureau the
secret history of the FBI is published
by st.